un gang de deux roues droit vers la
grotte de massabielle
dans les années 70 lourde était devenu
un lieu de pèlerinage pour motards
assise ou couchée sur leurs machines
ils ont écouté et participer à la messe
dite à leur intention
et puis le soir ils sont repartis comme
ils étaient venus à moto des motos sur
les pelouses du sanctuaire des images
inconcevable aujourd'hui l'accès ne se
fait qu'à pied il était environ six ans
à venir prier la vierge ou bien faire
bénir leurs engins chaque année jusqu'en
1975 le pèlerinage des bikers à notre
dame de lourdes et remise au goût du
jour en 1990 à l'intérieur la messe
toujours et aux abords du sanctuaire la
bénédiction point d'orgue d'un week end
de pèlerinage j'ai aussi une façon de
dire aux seigneurs ou de dire à marie ne
conçoit pas imprudent protège nous à
deux roues ils sont chaque année autour
de 1000 motards à rouler direction
lourdes
tous ne sont pas croyants mais tous font
partie d'une même communauté vulnérable
sur les routes
l'idée serait bien qu'une fois quand
même dans l'année on rassemble se
rassembler puis si vous pouvez avoir une
prière un moment
de fraternité sur lequel on ne peut pas
aisé à notre cher qu'on a perdu déjà un
événement à part dans la cité mariale
le pèlerinage motard s'est entouré de
spécificité au fil du temps en 2009 par
exemple un groupe de rock local en
pleine messe ou bien en 2010 une prière
spécialement rédigée pour les
conducteurs autre rituel immuable depuis
le tout début
une moto est autorisé à entrer dans le
sanctuaire pour déposer un cierge sous
la grotte des apparitions symbole de
lumière et de protection
[Musique]